Encuentra a "x" y verifica tu respuesta.
Donde "x" entre 3 es igual a 14.
Ok, tenemos aquí esta ecuación que nos dice
que la variable "x",
que es la que estamos buscando, si la
dividimos entre 3 nos da 14.
Y para encontrar el valor que debe de tomar
esta variable "x" para que se satisfaga esta ecuación,
o sea para que "x" entre 3 sea igual a 14,
lo que tenemos que hacer
es hacer que se quede la "x" solita del
lado izquierdo del igual.
Y bueno, tener "x" entre 3 es exactamente
lo mismo a tener 1/3 multiplicando a "x",
cierto, entonces estas dos ecuaciones realmente
nos están diciendo exactamente lo mismo.
Ahora, ¿cómo le vamos a hacer para que la
"x" se quede solita del lado izquierdo?
Pues que la "x" se quede solita del lado izquierdo,
significa que tenemos aquí "x" por 1,
o sea una sola "x" y pues lo que podemos hacer es
multiplicar por 3, o sea porque aquí la "x"
la estamos multiplicando por 3 y dividiendo
entre 3 y entonces estos dos se van a cancelar
y nos va a quedar "x" por 1 que es simplemente "x".
Ahora, hay que recordar que todo lo que hagamos
del lado izquierdo del igual,
lo tenemos que hacer también del lado derecho,
para que se preserve esta igualdad.
Ok, y lo mismo sucede en esta ecuación,
de hecho vamos a hacerlo para que veas que realmente son la misma ecuación.
Aquí multiplicamos por 3 y éste se va a
cancelar con éste
y aquí también tenemos que multiplicar por 3.
Entonces lo que tenemos es cualquier cosa,
que es nuestra "x",
dividida entre 3 y después multiplicada por 3, o sea, la dejamos tal cual como está,
igual a 14 por 3, 14 por 3 es 42.
Y lo mismo pasa por acá, 3 por 1/3 es lo
mismo que 3 por 1 entre 3,
o sea un 1 por cualquier cosa...
1 por cualquier cosa es esa misma cosa,
o sea "x"...
ya la tenemos por acá...
"x" igual a 14 por 3 que es 42, muy bien.
Ahora lo que vamos a hacer es verificar que
esta respuesta, o sea que "x"
sea igual a 42, es una respuesta correcta.
Y la forma de hacer eso es sustituir 42 en
lugar de la "x", tenemos que ver que si ponemos
el 42 en lugar del "x", o sea si ponemos 42
entre 3, eso es exactamente igual a 14, ok,
¿y cuánto es 42 entre 3?
42 entre 3 es 14, ok, y 14 si es igual a 14,
entonces...
¡Listo!
ya verificamos nuestra respuesta.
42 si lo dividimos entre 3,
sí es igual a 14.